24th captain in their history he's looking for
his first goal of the year goalis in 16 games
if he at back to last season and he starts this
game up front between Casper capital and pavl
bich and now Quinn Hughes able to slide the puck
ahead to Neils hogland nice lead pass here's lafy
breaking in Sam laford to the m hit the post
got past the goal tender Bennington nice little
saucer pass and he is gone outweighs benington
but boy just near side post through the blue
paint tries to play the puck in con intercept
here's a lead pass to dppi besser takes his Fe
he shoots and missed the net dinnington might have
got a little piece of it get for the Vancouver con
Brock besser playing that shot just TI feeds one
back Canucks changing while controlling Blues have
some tired bodies up there ederson fakes the shot
heric as well feeds down Queen Hughes wrist shot
blocked Paro got in front of it tried to clear it
but Hughes keeps the puck in now the Canucks have
five fresh skaters out there as hoglander tried
to bank that one and I think then it went off
his skate and off the side of the goal puck
sent around Heron over to keep it in here's
heroni to Hughes all the blues over a minute
and a half as Hughes scores [Music] [Applause]
you just felt like eventually the dam was going to
break and Quinn Hughes scores the opening goal at
759 to make it one nothing Vancouver the play
alive in the offensive zone you know You' got
some tired forwards against and the cans do
just that move the puck around holy Blues in
their defensive position and just a real smart
shot from Quinn Hughes low glove this eludes
the glove side of Bennington off the post and in
he was his second of the Season finally got the
setup they wanted in a great shot for kzo here he
is again takes the shot puts it in front besser
blocked Bennington diving back I don't know if
he got in front of it or the defenseman in front
of it this is when it was put out front there's
the right skate of c and helping out his goal
tender reference when the were in Philadelphia
they could have played for 3 days and maybe not
generated any goals and so the kxs see if they
can't give themselves the lead here add to it
as an 18-year-old emergency call up for the
Kings right yes I remember that Nick here's
Hughes back [Applause] [Music] one making four
goals in his last two games against St Louis the
blues the only team he has more goals against
than assists and Quinn Hughes with his second
of the night makes it two nothing face off win
back to the point Hughes a shimmy a shake and
looking for bodies in front and it goes off
the skate of Kevin Hayes as Bennington was
leaving the post area on his glove side thinking
someone's going to convert this and there's the
inside left heel two nothing conu Thomas sends
the puck around K's on now gets it to Freedman
coming off the right point in front tick on
goal and M the rebound put it just wild oh
what a wonderful stop by Bennington getting his
right leg up in the air came with the original
tip and then just couldn't get the second
chance to go Paro clears the puck out and
Tyler Myers Banks it the other way M didn't
get much on it as he tried to backand it in
here's Ley passing across to Colton Paro sad
takes a lead pass and converging on him were
Susi and Myers to break it up now Tyler Myers
up the middle D just set he's in on [Applause]
go two goals in a minute 10 and the
Canucks are up by three darts right
between the defenseman it's an excellent
pass keeps skating goes to his forehead
and Von you see that he thought he had that
angle covered and it gets slipped past him
Myers with the up byce pass this is a great
camera angle and try to set up in the vancou
zone Tory crew gave it away to Pon pass
Miller's alone short-handed TG Miller [Applause]
scores
[Applause] he had five short-handed goals last
year now he's got the first of the season for
the Canucks and they lead four to nothing Pon
is's able to come up with the puck right there
it's right on his table s a pass Miller holds
for long enough to get Bennington down and then
the backand Finish grou just puts it right on
the tape of Patterson and the con pile up the
goals B nvit penalty's over Hees out of the box
but the blues still have the puck and that one hit
the crossbar which n it Shang it off the bar and
out of play picked off by Thomas Kyu Le for Robert
Thomas feeds one diagonally back Paro with
a shot hit Escape Thomas on the rebound and
dco stayed with that pinballing puck to slide to
his right and make the save joshu going his stick
on that pass could clear it out 45 seconds
on power play Shen brings it in front got
on the forand and Demco stayed right with him
good pass and the spin move Demco finding the
rebound and the conu will try to take this one
home you wonder how much ice time the likes of
Miller and B [Music] Edon certainly Quinn
Hughes might see in the third period here
with that Rangers game luming they want to make
sure they get this one through to the finish line
of course but want to be a little bit fresh
for the game 24 hours from there and taco was
talking this morning about looking to get more
ice time to some of those players who deserve
just couldn't throughout that road strip Conor
Garland's name came up chance early and Demco
maybe his best save thus far as this is bumped
to him he finishes his curl and trying to go on
the blocker side Demco though just making it
look common place with his saves had a couple
of those and just missed the mark yeah still
looking for his first point now here's Garland
with a step C Garland Put It [Applause] Wide
another chance on a turnover laery tried to put
it on the back hand Hughes gets the puck but
he bobbled It perona cast The Hustle back to
get there ahead of Shan who Gets behind him Gren
Shan get go with the right pass strips the puck
off ponic tries to outweigh Demco Demco the C
after the puck Blues find it first Thomas now
vavich to borzo back to Pavo bich who shoots
Demco with the left pad flashed it out to make
the save and here's Pon the other way checked
but following on is Kenco to Pon to [Applause]
mck all three line makes are in on that one
and M makes it five nothing get to this Puck
first and then kzo makes a nice pass back to
pson moves it up to M and five hole for five
nothing I've said before if they handed
out third assist at the end P nvic almost
gave it away but it got past Hughes here's
Thomas in on the right wing Robert Thomas to
fall Demco sliding across made another save
he's tracking the puck so well tonight back
checking Hughes and Demco there are no holes
there and he's content just to BU the pucker
Darin gets it on the far side and that's
going to do it another convincing home I
victory for the Vancouver kcks that's
demo with his fourth career shut out